[Música]
bienvenidos a cinco minutos con estamos
con el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france24 doctor pérez inició
preguntándole américa latina atraviesa
un nuevo pico de contagios lo que ha
llevado a una mayor presión sobre los
sistemas de salud cuál es la situación
de las unidades de cuidados intensivos
que puede ocurrir si se alcanza el
colapso
valentina una de las situaciones es que
la unidad intensiva es el paso final o
el último momento en donde un paciente
con kobe puede salir adelante estas
unidades son limitadas
no solamente por la demanda tecnológica
sino por la capacidad humana y un punto
de inflexión en la pandemia es si se
colapsa o no las unidad de contención
hoy estamos en una situación crítica por
la falta de insumos no tanto por la
falta de camas o ventiladores sino con
lo que se necesita atender por eso los
llamados de la prevención y el control
de la pandemia no es incrementar el
número de cuidados de camas de
contenidos sino evitar que la gente
llega a las unidades de intensivos y por
eso debemos mantener esa pedagogía
social que hemos hecho durante este
tiempo la organización mundial de la
salud advirtió sobre el incremento de la
incidencia del cobre 19 en grupos
etáreos mayer en grupos etáreos más
jóvenes hay más jóvenes internados en
estas unidades de terapia intensiva
si eso es cierto y son enfermedades que
afectan a personas jóvenes ya con las
comorbilidades siguen siendo importantes
pero hay personas jóvenes sin
comorbilidades también estamos
encontrando mujeres embarazadas jóvenes
de 30 a 25 ó 40 años que requieren una
unidad de contención y esto hace que sea
mucho más demandante porque los
pacientes jóvenes requieren más atención
y pues es mayor el número de contagios
en gente joven también menos la
probabilidad de ofrecer cada más parte
de cuidado intensivo estamos viendo un
cambio en la enfermedad y hoy se afecta
a población joven y población embarazada
que nos preocupa mucho usted es un
momento mencionaba que además de la
falta de camas también hay faltantes de
otros elementos que insumos faltan que
insumos se requieren
además del oxígeno que se ha visto en
varios países de latinoamérica que hay
disminución el aporte de los relajantes
musculares de los sedantes de los de los
medicamentos que se requieren para la
atención de un paciente en grado crítico
es un paciente muy complejo y se
requieren varias intervenciones
farmacéuticas farmacológicas de
oxigenoterapia y eso se requiere en
estos insumos estos insumos están
faltando
por la gran demanda que hay porque es
alguna acción inusitada pero también
porque tenemos restricciones en la
movilidad nosotros no somos productores
nosotros somos consumidores de estos
elementos y eso hace que nosotros
retiramos un esfuerzo adicional para
poder conseguir y seguir atendiendo a
los pacientes críticos doctor llevamos
más de un año de pandemia encima cómo se
sienten los médicos muchas veces no solo
tienen que luchar contra la enfermedad
sino también en muchos casos contra
condiciones precarias laborales
sin duda es una situación de agobio y
desbordado pero un mensaje también
importante es que si algo ha demostrado
el carácter en esta pandemia han sido
los trabajadores de la salud han
mantenido su disciplina nunca se ha
buscado un protagonismo y siguen
haciendo el trabajo ojalá salgamos
fortalecidos y entendamos que los
trabadores de la salud no son héroes son
simplemente personas que hacen su
trabajo por vocación amor y servicio y
que todo lo que se le puede ofrecer para
unas condiciones dignas de su trabajo va
a ser recompensada en una sociedad más
justa y mejor atendida en estas
situaciones de crisis es el peor momento
de la pandemia en muchos países
latinoamericanos pero para los gobiernos
cada vez es más difícil maniobrar entre
restricciones más duras y la situación
económica y social que medidas alternas
se pueden implementar es necesario
volver a un confinamiento duro
los confinamientos son solamente medidas
reactivas y hemos visto el gran desgaste
social y el gran impacto social que lo
que estamos viendo la pandemia pobreza
es la respuesta a todas estas acciones
sociales que estamos viendo en estos
momentos probablemente lo que retiramos
es vacunas nosotros lo que necesitamos
para reactivar la economía para que las
cosas vuelvan normal y vuelvan a la
normalidad es bajo unas tenemos procesos
de vacunación que son hasta ahora el
necesitamos muchas más vacunas mucha más
decisión y una concertación y una
equidad en la adquisición de las vacunas
para que sean para todo el mundo en este
momento estamos en priorización pero
realmente en la región necesitamos
vacunar a una forma mucho más acelerada
porque la única forma de poder tener un
equilibrio social
los aquí los confinamientos son
solamente medidas activas doctora usted
muchas gracias por su análisis y a
ustedes por su sintonía continúen con
nosotros aquí en france 24
[Música]